contrôler sa douleur a toujours été un
rêve pour l'homme parce que si on
contrôle sa douleur on contrôler sa peur
la peur a entre autres comme origine le
fait d'avoir mal qui est le premier
signal de danger physique alors
certaines personnes ne ressentent pas la
douleur par contre ils ressentent les
sensations classiques comme le toucher
la chaleur la différence de température
ce genre de choses c'est la même chose
que la chaleur oui mais si l'information
devient trop forte
ils deviennent insensibles comme de
super héros des super héros je pense pas
que eux le vois comme ça surtout si on
regarde l'histoire de steven pitt qui a
justement j'ai littéralement un quart de
sa langue sans s'en rendre compte
c'est gênant ça fait des économies sur
les courses mais c'est gênant jusqu'à
l'âge de 12 ans il était quasiment tout
le temps plâtre et quelque part et sa
plus grande crainte aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir une blessure interne ou de faire
une crise d'appendicite et de pas
ressentir cette douleur la voilà ça sent
le mental vlog bien joyeux génériques
salut aujourd'hui je suis toujours
malade et du coup j'avais envie de vous
parler de la douleur
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur steven
pitt dont je vous ai parlé juste là à
l'instant il est atteint d'un
dysfonctionnement d'un gène du gène scn
9 ha oui c'est ça et je vous met à lire
dans la description vers l'interview
qu'il a donnée à la bbc depuis des
années 1990
on cherche à visualiser dans le cerveau
ou sucrés la douleur et comment ça
fonctionne on cherche à cartographier un
petit peu la douleur d'abord aux états
unis et depuis quelques années en france
plus précisément à lyon où le
neurophysiologiste luis garcia larrea
tente de développer des marqueurs de la
perception douloureuse dans le cerveau
il a vite compris avec son équipe qui
avait pas un centre de la douleur
spécifique mais que certaines régions
s'occupent de différents aspects de la
douleur
néanmoins il en ressort que le ressenti
de cette dernière reste inique à chaque
individu à chaque personne une étude de
2016 de mars 2016 je crois que je vous
mets également dans la description à
trouver une information essentielle un
élément essentiel sur ce qu'est la
douleur cette information précise
l'ocytocine aurait le rôle le plus
important dans la modulation de la
perception de la douleur donc plus fort
ou surtout moins fort mais en
l'occurrence trente scientifiques
internationaux qui ont été dirigés par
alexandre charles ix au cnrs se sont
penchés sur cette substance très mal
connue pour faire très simple en gros
l'ocytocine est synthétisée entre autres
par l'hypothalamus
et s'il n'ya pas réellement de zones de
la douleur dans le cerveau comme on a pu
voir là un instant avec l'étude
lyonnaise le cern lui a découvert une
zone un petit peu antidouleur où je
stoppe la douleur 30 neurones je fais ça
parce qu'ils ont un peu plus petit les
autres il décide de libérer l'ocytocine
en réveillant autour d'eux toujours dans
l'hypothalamus ça se passe dans deux
zones différentes des plus gros neurones
et leur disent allez-y les gars on
envoie la sauce dans le sens là nous on
va s'occuper de la moelle épinière vous
vous occupez d'envoyer d'ocytocine dans
le sang et l'or via les gros neurones
l'ocytocine est envoyé dans le sang est
elle pas dans les neurones périphériques
des régions ou de la zone douloureuse et
la drogue
un petit peu en fait il faut non mais ça
va on l'a plus mal il engourdissent
réellement toute la zone i drogue la
sensation douleur et en même temps en
simultané l'ocytocine passe par la
moelle épinière pour attaquer
directement le
inial montant le message envoyé par les
nerfs qui va dire au cerveau attention
là on a super mal à cet endroit là donc
en fait l'ocytocine elle va traiter la
conséquence la au cerveau et en même
temps elle va diminuer le signal montant
et c'est très intéressant parce que si à
terme on arrive à maîtriser sa en
médecine ça voudra dire qu'on pourra
soulager les gens par exemple qui ont
une douleur pathologique
en attendant vous pour gérer votre
douleur suivant le type de douleur que
c'est vous pouvez aller voir par exemple
un hypnothérapeute ça fonctionne très
bien vous pouvez faire plus simplement
des exercices de relaxation comme on l'a
déjà vu dans d'anciennes vidéos
oui ici sur cette chaîne autre hypothèse
en méditant il ya des scientifiques qui
ont émis l'hypothèse c'est à dire on se
calme oui ça n'a pas été vérifiée ils
ont dit ça comme ça c'est une hypothèse
que la méditation était peut-être le
secret des moines shaolin pour se
libérer de la sensation de douleur
ce qui m'amène à une question des amis
est ce que vous aimeriez que dans une
vidéo je parle de méditation et surtout
des techniques de méditation
personnellement je pratique samoa depuis
plusieurs années sa mère dans plein de
choses également pour refaire un peu le
tri dans la mémoire pour calmer un petit
peu le mental je pourrais vous en parler
un petit peu mais je voudrais être sûr
avant que ça vous plaît alors si c'est
le cas vous me le dites dans les
commentaires on en parle ensemble je
laissais passer quelques jours je ferai
ma petite étude dans les commentaires et
je ferai ça en fonction j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu maintenant je
vais me soigner un petit peu mais vous
pouvez m'aider à guérir en laissant un
pouce en l'air non ça n'a aucun sens
mais si la vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez
en laisser un vous pouvez également vous
abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
puisque mon talent blog c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au
31 décembre
donc rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
m